well what did you expect last night
Chris DP I don't know what to expect
this series has been very difficult to
call just when you think one team has
the momentum it turns out to be the
other it it's been a funny series man I
have that you know I I kind of council
my prediction no mid weight during a
season I mean during this series because
it's just been so up and down uh but
definitely I definitely thought once the
Cavaliers got that game five it over
that it was anybody series and that's
proven is back there right now all right
if you're a Cavs fan how's your morale
going to oakland for game 7 they feel
good they feel good which is certainly
uncommon around these parts because you
know we know history but the way that
the Warriors have looked over the last
couple of games they've looked to
moralize they've looked out of sync
their office hasn't been in a rhythm
Stephan curry has found he is but
everybody else seen has has lost that
fault uh you know everybody including
myself was kind of calling Andre
Iguodala the LeBron you know container
he's definitely contained the bra to a
certain extent in those first couple of
games of the series but LeBron is dug
deep and found something and I don't
know what he's done exactly but he's
turned into that unstoppable force that
we've seen over the last couple of years
so definitely man I think the morale of
the cavaliers fan base is definitely sky
I really do think they feel entertain
feels that it can get Game seven what
role if any do you think Klay Thompson's
comments or draymond greens comments to
LeBron James have played and how are you
played into how he's performed here
recently Singh recently I think I think
he's definitely agitated LeBron James
and his teammates you know there was a
lot of jolly you know I would say there
was some back-and-forth Zoe I know
Shannon fly has some words to say
in response to the wars and you know
obviously we know what claire and dre
said you know they were up 3-1 at that
point and you know nobody has ever came
back from 31 deficits 32 teen different
teams you know 32 teams of try and that
fail uh yeah I think they're talking
came a little bit too prematurely
obviously we shall see that now but
definitely I think it ignited a fire not
only with their LeBron James within that
whole camp and I think they've rallied
around them what did the brunt did
anybody ask what LeBron said to Steph
Curry when you belong to shunt either he
didn't want to eat he didn't discuss EEE
wouldn't go there he wouldn't go there
but I will say this DP you know bringing
up you know talking about LeBron a step
LeBron has taken on this dark Hill
enrolled I'm in a process of life
writing this now and LeBron you know
ordinarily he doesn't thrive in that
bill in that dark role but he saw a
full-on heal this last week you know he
was seen wearing a black Undertaker
shirt he made the call for the team to
wear the black sleeve jerseys in Game
five and they won it last night the team
came out took the court to Undertaker
steam music and so like he's falling
relishing in this dark villain role and
I think a lot of it has to do and this
is what I'm writing a lot of it has to
do with just how Stephan curry is seen
as this heavily figure throughout the
NBA and LeBron James always wanted to be
admired in such a way and but he's
realizing he's not winning that fight
she's not going to get those accolades
and so I think he's taken upon himself
to go all heal and I think he's
dominating that fashion in a way that
we've never seen LeBron James do it he's
uh chris haynes he covers the Cavaliers
for the Cleveland Plain Dealer joining a
Stan Patrick show then he should show up
on Sunday with a black cowboy hat on
Chris yeah I just take the court with
his eyes rolled up in the back there
yeah
hahaha I can see it that that's just how
LeBron is like he takes every little
thing it so hard and whatever he can use
his motivation he used it how do I
really don't think this is admiration I
really think he's been watching like
some old WWE undertaker um wrestling
events and using that to his advantage
that's the type of guy that he is and so
uh you know definitely they're going to
wear the black Steve jerseys on Sunday
but definitely I could probably see some
more theatrics from LeBron I mentioned
this in the first hour and of course
being from Ohio and understanding all of
this heartbreak the Cleveland fans have
had if I said you're going to lose the
finals you can pick game six at home or
game seven on the road what do you think
Cleveland fans would have opted for
probably game seven on the road just a
simple fact you know they the Cavaliers
players I know they were ticked off
curry made a comment when he came back
to play the cavs in January that he
hopes the locker room still smells like
champagne I loved a blue i love i love
that i loved it man i mean here's like
everybody looks at Steph Curry because
he has this angelic face he's more of a
junk talker cutthroat been LeBron is no
he is but he does it in a boy like wait
yeah like how can you take a fist to
that that's that's a curried it mean
anything by it you know it's like oh my
god you know it's almost like can't take
up this to why LeBron James sees that
here's all that and he's like hey that
was me for that so how would you
ridicule for a week that's true that's
true we play by different rules for
those guys Chris safe travels and good
luck with the lebron is now the villain
or playing the role of the villain
column for the Cleveland Plain Dealer
thanks def had me take care of a night
crew Saints the Dan Patrick show weekday
mornings on audience
you